foreign
black hoodie
with like uh Tampax
understand
ing
Air Force Base uh right by the reserves
reporters huh
get on the ground
I'll shoot you get on the fucking ground
get on the fucking ground put your hands
out put your hands out spread them out
spread them out
[Music]
keep your hands right there I will
fucking shoot you
you got him
back
here's the driver
all right what do you got what do you
need help with right now I just need
there's a dude in the driver's seat
who's slightly
out for him
on team just let 34 John know
start making the notification the state
highways for a complete closure on
Allentown at the front of Andrews Air
Force Base
I got me
the Suitland Road do we have an
overlapped spot working today
[Music]
thank you